My 18-year-old daughter was diagnosed with stage 2B melanoma a year ago. We've been
on a holistic health journey during this year, and her pediatric doctor had suggested she do a liver
cleanse. Her blood work showed elevated liver enzymes. My question concerned about the protocol of
the liver cleanse to do a large amount of apple juice for the malic acid benefit, but will the
high amount of sugar be bad for her as a cancer patient that will take to feed the cancer?
So do we a liver cleanse? First of all, I don't ever have any of my kids or patients do liver
cleanses, but I wouldn't do a liver cleanse if my alkaline boss or AST or ALT
came back elevated. I would try to figure out why it's elevated. Certainly, maybe this doctor did
and came to the assumption that you're congested liver. I got really big on liver cleanses, and the
reason is that, okay, so understand, in the liver, you have phase one, phase two, phase three,
detoxification pathways. These are controlled by different, dependent upon different nutrients and
controlled by different genetic pathways. Looking at, when we look at a person's genetic pathways,
if they have issues with their cytokine people, 50s or one pathways, they're NHG pathways and such,
then we try to support those pathways. I go into detail on this in my book, the seven phases
of detoxification and my course with that same name. So those three phases of three of the seven
phases of detoxification, many times you have elevated or liver enzymes because you have blockage
downstream from that. So you have congestion in the liver, not because we need to do a liver cleanse,
but we have congestion in the liver because of gallbladder issues. We have congestion in the liver
because of issues in the gut. So we always want to start as far downstream as possible, which is
what I call phase six. Then we work up phase five, phase four, and then you are supporting those
phase one, two, three pathways, necessarily doing a cleanse. Now the cleanse that this person's
talking about using apple juice, I think I'm familiar with that cleanse. We even have information
of that on our detox course, but it's really used to help with the gallbladder, helping to flush the
gallbladder. So the question is, should I be concerned with the sugar in the apple juice
to feed the cancer? So I guess my answer to that question would be no because you're doing this
for a week, typically. So the apple juice and the malic acid content for the apple juice is to help
soften the stones in the gallbladder. You may, prior to this desire to get an ultrasound or
the gallbladder to see what that looks like, that may be something you want to look at.
But I would also investigate other possible reasons why those liver insides are elevated because
they should not be elevated in an 18-year-old person. So lots of times liver insides can be elevated
due to even sensitivity to different nutrients. If you're taking high-dose nutrients and
the naturopathes put you on a bunch of different supplements that you may have,
because they have a sensitivity to it. Remember, anything that you take in and absorb that your
body can't use has to go through the liver to go through the detoxification process phase 1, 2, 3 to
get out of the body again. So anything that you absorb into the blood has to get out of the blood
or be deposited into the tissues. And if it's something even in nutrient that your body doesn't need,
it can't overstress the liver. So one of the mistakes that I see with people coming to me with
the cancer diagnosis, they're on, in my opinion, maybe way too much stuff. And too much of a good
thing can be a bad thing. So other things that can raise, most other most kind of things that could
raise liver insides is toxicity issue to a medication. So a person is out of medication. Even
ad bill or Tylenol, that's a major issue of raising liver enzymes. So I'd be
trying to investigate what's causing the elevation of the liver enzymes. Maybe you already did that.
I don't know. You're just asking a simple question here. So to answer the simple question,
what I'd be concerned about the glucose levels in the apple juice,
doing a week of the liver cleanse, I guess, no, I wouldn't be concerned about that.
But I do think it would be rather than not to give you that other information to investigate.